[Music]
foreign
hey you guys what's going on it's happy
Sunday the end of the weekend yeah
and we did we did [ __ ]
basically Tombstone which is shootout at
the okay Corral gunfighter there okay
well and and kind of things that happen
yeah underwear too what what they called
what do they call that the the Vendetta
ride or something like that it was a
crystal flick [ __ ] all-star cast
Louie sent it to us and yeah Lou here in
the comments he also sent us platoon so
that's probably what we're going to be
talking about on Tuesday yeah but there
it is yeah Blu-ray if you send us the
[ __ ] hard copy of a Blu-ray we'll do
the show I mean eventually I mean we
just happened to get to these there was
a couple times where we even forgot we
got like [ __ ] 30 of them at once and
then we had a pile and then I was like
wait did we do that one already yeah
yeah I know it's like yeah but in recent
years if you sent us something we'll do
it
um Tombstone great flick great flick
this is I forgot I saw this movie a long
time ago
um I don't think I saw in the theater
but I think I saw it on cable like a
year or two after it came out and I
remembered it being like really fun and
like really entertaining but I hadn't
seen it in a really long time so man
what a [ __ ] great cast yeah and it's
just
I was watching a video earlier about how
historically accurate it is and even
though it's not super accurate it's not
as inaccurate as it might seem
um it is kind of like romanticized
dramatized
um you know it has that like Love Story
kind of aspect which I kind of feel like
they could have done without but
honestly it's just so fun that I don't
even really care how accurate yeah it is
because it's just like such an
entertaining [ __ ] movie it's a good
movie as is yeah
um did it happen that way no not really
the show the shootout at the okay that's
pretty accurate that's pretty accurate
but the reasons behind it
nah not really
um
I was always under the impression that
it was player hate okay
the so-called Cowboys and in this movie
they make him seem like a gang
and I mean they make them like super
super better like literally like the
opening scene of the film is them like
shooting up a wedding yeah like just
killing everybody and that didn't happen
okay that didn't happen
uh the so-called Cowboys were not bad
guys they were just like the average Joe
of the time
um
I kind of think it was [ __ ] player
hate
it may have been what one of the things
that I was saying we were talking about
this before uh we started streaming I
was like I kind of feel like one of the
things even though this isn't like
totally historically accurate I do like
that they portrayed Wyatt Earp and like
his you know his guys and Doc Holliday
and everything like that as morally
ambiguous like which is closer to what
they were like in real life yeah because
I kind of feel like prior to this like
when you had westerns like from the 50s
and 60s and everything like Wyatt Earp
they would kind of seems like he's the
good guy you know what I mean it was
just like very black and white and
that's actually not the way it was I
mean like Wyatt Earp I think that he
like didn't he he was like a pimp for a
while like I think he ran a brothel yeah
I'm pretty sure that's where he met his
wife who I think was it was common law
wife I don't think they actually like it
yeah and that wasn't really a criminal
profession no no I'm just saying that
I'm just saying that I don't think they
would have put that like in the 50s or
60s and Doc Holliday was a was a Coke
feed he was a was a dentist but he
walked around with a [ __ ] jar of
cocaine did he press as one does yeah
and you know you'd play cards and
[ __ ] spoon cocaine into wine and
drink it they didn't snort it
uh but that might have been one of the
reasons why he was such a fast gun uh
Coke okay one of the things that I read
was that he it wasn't so much that he
was faster than everyone else but he was
just like a lot cooler under pressure
right um and that was what made him a
good gunfighter is he didn't get rattled
and His Hands didn't shake and he had
really good aim you know yeah that's
something I wanted to say it's called
taking your time in a hurry yeah okay he
was good at that if you're
if you have any background of firearms
and and [ __ ] uh say infantry style
combat like I I have it I grew up
shooting guns
rushing yourself will cause yourself to
Fumble everything is about staying very
cool and to be very [ __ ] slick
um I think a lot of [ __ ]
um SWAT teams say fast is smooth and
smooth as fast is one of the things that
they say
you don't rush yourself you take your
time
in a hurry
which is
yeah I know it takes an uh it's an art
it's an art form into itself yeah why
you're being shot at yeah okay
um
I was always under the impression that
the so-called Cowboys they were younger
we know that's for true
I think they were younger in that I
think they were hotter than [ __ ]
Wyatt Earp and his boys who were more
established and I think
the Cowboys they were worried about were
younger hotter guys
uh I'm gonna default to the gutter the
lowest common denominator okay well that
was how [ __ ] went back yeah that's the
way it went back then I think what it
really was is that Wyatt and his buddies
were older
they had their grip on the feet the
local females
uh who were mostly professionals if you
understand what I'm saying
um and they didn't want to give that
grip up
and and a new bunch of younger guys were
showing up
who were cuter
and I think the girls were paying them
more attention and they had to get rid
of those guys they had to get them out
of town
and uh that led to this shootout
that's what I think happened
based on my readings
going back to the [ __ ] 80s and 90s
that's what I think happened
but this is still a great movie not
accurate but yeah like I said not
totally accurate but that's okay
um and honestly like the guy that
directed this I had forgotten about this
but the guy that directed uh George
cosmatos cosmatos cosmetos I'm not
really sure it's a Greek last name he is
the same guy that directed uh Rambo
First Blood Part Two and Cobra yeah uh
cover was a good flip and Leviathan
which actually I like Leviathan I
haven't seen it a long time I did see
that in the theater
but I had yeah I had forgotten like I
remembered that uh Crystal was in this
and I remember that Val Kilmer was in it
but I forgot like about this Justin was
in it yes and I was just like okay yeah
man everybody's in his powers booths
that Bill Paxton was in it Michael Bain
was in it everybody isn't Sam Elliott's
in it and everybody has epic stashes and
they're all real apparently that's what
they that's what they said on like all
the um uh on the promotional materials
they were very proud of the fact that
everyone grew well Sam Elliott always
had an epic stash but everybody else had
to grow one and the thing about look as
much as I love Kurt Russell and he's
great in this even though this movie I
mean it came out in 1993 and you were
saying like after we watched it you said
that seems like like a very retro like I
mean to it was by today's standards yeah
it was it is very I don't want to say
over Rock because that sounds like I'm
[ __ ] on it and I'm not it's very
like dramatic like you know what I mean
when there's like dramatic stuff
happening there's like lightning and a
lightning storm and everything is like
it's not very subtle I guess is what I'm
saying but it's just so funny it's
almost like operatic at times but it's
like I think that's what makes it so
entertaining because the thing about it
was 1993 six months after this came out
another movie called Wyatt Earp came out
yeah like with Kevin Costner in it which
I don't think I ever saw I'm not like a
big westerns person so I wouldn't
normally like seek them out but I liked
all the actors in this so I did see this
I will say though that as much as I love
Kurt Russell you have to be like pretty
[ __ ] awesome to steal a movie from
Kurt Russell but Val Kilmer absolutely
does into this Val Kilmer just picks up
this movie and runs away with it Miles
and Miles I mean he is so people were
talking at the time that he should have
got an Oscar nomination but uh he didn't
but he absolutely should have he kills
it he kills it in this role he's so
killer did a great [ __ ] job in the in
that Doors movie too though that's
another one that's another one we should
review at some point because I remember
really liking that too I think I saw
that movie look at Jenny's glasses
aren't those [ __ ] cute yeah
he's been gone for like five hours and
then he comes back and he's like
I was like no I'm [ __ ] up I like are
we gonna be able to do the show I'm
[ __ ] up I was talking to biker gangs
all [ __ ] talking to biker gangs yeah
Ford throw down said yeah also William
Peterson Billy Bob Thornton yeah I
didn't even actually I forgot I didn't
recognize Billy Bob Thornton he's only
in it for like a couple of minutes and
Jason Priestley yeah he was only in it
for a couple scenes too I recognized him
it's an All-Star cast I mean every
[ __ ] is in this everybody really I'm
in this problem yeah Jenny's in there
I could possibly I could possibly be
it's the kind of movie that's like a
must-see
especially for the 90s I mean you know
it was a 90s [ __ ] movie but it it's a
good Western
very American
um
it's a little bit dated I think by
today's standards but that's not a bad
thing it's just it's just the way it was
I mean it's a product of its time but
like I said it's a little bit I mean
particularly that one scene the one
scene that I'm thinking of mostly is uh
the one scene where
uh where spoiler alert Wyatt Earp kills
uh you know curly Bell who's played by
Powers Booth and like they have honestly
that gun fight like that where they have
it like the um the lake or the creek or
whatever the [ __ ] that is like in the
woods they're like that's pretty much
how it happened they said that according
to all the witnesses like Wyatt Earp
absolutely just did come out from the
hiding spot and bullets were whizzing at
them all around and miraculously like
none of them hit him and he just came
and like [ __ ] blew Curly Bill away
but the best thing about that is there's
like a close-up of Kurt Russell he's
like he's coming out and he's going no
no and then he's like no like you
[ __ ] it's so awesome I love it so
much it's just like it's so so cheesy
but it goes all the way around like and
just becomes awesome again and there's a
couple scenes like that in this that are
like really really over the top like
that but they totally work and I think
it's just because
I don't know like I said just the whole
tone of it it's not a comedy but it's
just like the I really like that's why I
kind of feel like I really like Val
Kilmer's character because he's just so
droll and sarcastic and like they all of
them are kind of like that so there's
like a lot of this kind of like dry
humor in it so then when it sort of like
goes over the top like that it's just it
totally works I don't know just the vibe
of this whole movie like totally works
for me I think so but I hadn't seen it
in such a long time so it was like
really fun now like I said one thing
that I kind of wish that they had cut
out the kind of romance subplot like
between
um you know Russell and that uh that
woman that actress yeah because that
didn't really I mean I don't know I
don't really add it all that much like
like I said like her character is cool
and everything like that but I don't
really think the movie really needed
that I think what they were doing is
they were trying to depart from the
spaghetti western and when you say
spaghetti western it almost sounds
derogatory it's not
um [ __ ] a lot of the Italian westerns
were better than the American westerns
during the [ __ ] 70s all right uh
uh [ __ ]
the uh The Man With No Name Trilogy you
know like uh what they had
um
[ __ ] what what I [ __ ] up dude Clint
Eastwood Clint Eastwood yeah the Clint
Eastwood movies at the very beginning
they were [ __ ] rewriting the Western
because
the American Western of the 60s and the
70s was
pretty [ __ ]
um
[ __ ] when you look at it it was very
uh
um what's good generic
then you had like the Italians coming in
like Sergio Leone and they were making
it post-apocalyptic which is really kind
of what the Southwest was about it was
the end of the the Mexican Empire in the
beginning of the American Empire
and uh Leone and his [ __ ] scores okay
Sergio Leone's scores were [ __ ]
awesome all right and
um they rewrote and revitalized the
Western oh big time Big Time
and then and then [ __ ] Eastwood later
on in his own Productions
carried on the spaghetti western under
the American batter Banner you know
[ __ ]
um High Plains Drifter
[ __ ]
Pale Rider
all those movies those were Spaghetti
Westerns rebooted as American [ __ ] okay
well
this movie is kind of a spaghetti
western
uh a traditional American western movie
really wouldn't have been this good
just go back to the 50s and see what
they were doing like you know
well they had kind of gotten stale and
like I said I think they got too hung up
in the whole you know white black hat
yeah um you know good guy bad guy like I
said being very very like black and
white like these are obviously the good
guys and these are obviously the bad
guys and I'm like well the real wild
west wasn't like it wasn't like that so
I think it like took the Italians to
like inject some moral ambiguity into it
which made them a lot better and more
interesting and even though this has I
mean like we were saying before like um
Tombstone does actually have it makes
the Cowboys like the gang like seem a
lot worse than they were
um but at least it you know because it
makes them like very very clearly the
bad guys but at least but at least it
introduces like some moral ambiguity to
Wyatt Earp and Doc Holliday and like all
of those guys because that's more like
what it was really like like they
weren't like Wyatt Earp and his brothers
they weren't all good guys neither and
Doc Holliday I think he murdered a guy
yeah well and actually Wyatt Earp later
and they I don't think they show this in
the movie exactly the way it really
happened but um that one [ __ ] dude oh
[ __ ] man what's that dude's name that he
shot like um I'll think of it in a
second but the one guy that uh he shot
like at the train station like while he
was while Virgil was um after Virgil got
shot in the arm like that one guy
um he actually just [ __ ] shot him
like in Cold Blood the dude was like not
armed or anything I think in the movie
like you know they kind of like massaged
it a little bit so he didn't seem like
so cold-blooded but he did actually like
shoot that guy one thing that has to be
understood about the old west
Law Men of the old west the good ones
were not really good dudes they were
kind of like the Boba Fett's of their
time they were gray yeah they were
Mercenaries
uh and a lot of them had criminal pass
you know you can't be a good law man
unless you're a criminal because you
have to know how a criminal thinks a lot
of those guys were Train Robbers and
bank robbers well I think like I said in
this like Doc Holiday yeah they showed
him in this as being like a gambler and
like you like robbed some casinos and
stuff like that which I think he did do
but um yeah he had he had I think like
Rob some stage coaches or you've done
some [ __ ] like that and I think he
murdered a dude too like um you know and
he got in trouble for that but it's
really the best guys you need for
law enforcement in that era you don't
need Boy Scouts you want criminals
that you can pay off and to flip them
over to your side
to catch other criminals
which is some which is one of the
factors why in this movie they're saying
well the law doesn't go here we don't
like it because
it didn't really have a lot of
legitimacy a lot of the guys enforcing
the law were breaking the law just a few
years prior right you know so so
everyone is just kind of like why the
[ __ ] should we listen to you you're
doing the same [ __ ] that we're doing
right right which they like I said they
do kind of address that in this
um you know it's you know they tone it
down a little bit like I said to make it
seem like Kurt Russell and them are like
you know obviously more obviously the
good guys but there was like a lot more
uh ambiguous [ __ ] going on and like I
said they do make they kind of made it
seem like um well no this was actually
true because like the law in Tombstone
when they got there they were actually I
don't know if really like the whole
entire town was like under the thumb of
the Cowboys but for for sure like the
law was kind of like cooperating with
them yeah and like I said it was a lot
more morally ambiguous because after the
gun fight at the okay Corral when a lot
of the Cowboys like one of those guys
like the Clinton gang and everything
like when they got killed like it it
divided the town in half because half of
the town thought that uh you know Wyatt
Earp and them were Heroes and they were
Justified and the other half thought
that they just killed all these people
that were unarmed and that they should
like go to jail now slash of red
mentions that Eastwood was in the
classic television series Rawhide
uh yeah I remember Rawhide and Rawhide
from what I remember kind of had a dark
Edge to it it was closer to a spaghetti
western I haven't seen it within it
within that then that was a traditional
western movie uh traditional Western
[ __ ] would be like gun smoke or Bonanza
uh which was and I liked Bonanza but um
it was very black and white very good
guy bad guy
uh from what I remember raw from what I
remember of Rawhide Rawhide was a little
Gray from what I remember
which may have helped Sergio Leone pick
um
uh [ __ ] uh Eastwood
hang them high is a great flick go back
and watch Hang Em High
in that movie Eastwood is a good guy
but he's serving A system that is very
gray they're hanging people that don't
really don't deserve to be hanged
you know and that's the way it was
it was gray yeah
and I mean I like that they kind of show
in this one because we did a show about
I mean we did didn't we do a show about
like Wyatt Earp or the gunfighter that
okay girl or something like that we
didn't like a show about western or
something like that like a while back
but and I think we maybe brought this up
on there but I'm glad they show in the
movie that because like I said the
gunfight at the okay Corral the way they
show it in this movie is pretty accurate
I think the only thing that's inaccurate
is like the one guy that the clan guy
that he I think it's like Clanton that
he lets get away and then like it goes
into the building and like starts
shooting at him like he did let the guy
get away like after the dude ran at him
but the guy didn't like uh steal a gun
and start shooting at him again from the
window that's like I think the only
thing that's inaccurate but I did like
that they showed that the um the the
sheriff it was the sheriff right
or whoever like comes to like while um
you know Wyatt Earp and Doc Holiday and
them are going to the okay Corral like
to confront the gang
um you know the sheriff says hey I
already disarmed them like don't go
there like don't worry about it and then
like wide open them just go they go
anyway you know what I mean because they
actually put them on trial like wide
open because the dudes were not armed
like two of them were armed but you know
they clearly were not gunning for a
fight at the time that Wyatt Earp in
them like approached them so there was
like oh there was a big question at the
time like as to where the fault lay with
it because obviously like and like I
said that divided the whole town
afterward and there was that whole thing
too like that guy
um the one Sheriff like the older guy
like getting shot in the street like by
Curly Bill
um that was actually that did happen but
in the movie they kind of made it seem
like that's when they banned guns in uh
Tombstone but actually they didn't ban
them for like six more months like after
that happened but it was stuff like that
like the stuff that happened in the
movie like his other brother getting
shot Bill Paxton like getting shot like
in the saloon while he was playing pool
that did happen and that happened pretty
much the way you say it and see it in
the movie but it happened like at a
different time than what they showed it
they just like compressed everything I
kind of feel like just which is what
they usually do in movies they'll just
like combine some [ __ ] and all that kind
of stuff but yeah and it was I don't
know but so like I said this is like I
don't know I this was just such a great
movie such a great cast uh Val Kilmer
I had forgotten like how [ __ ] good
Val Kilmer was in this like I said he
just totally his golden years he [ __ ]
steals this movie and I mean you have to
be like a big deal to steal a movie from
this [ __ ] stacked ass cast you know
what I mean that he just like takes it
off but he just like runs with it man
he's just like so so good and he's so
good because he's like funny but he's
also like really
sympathetic you know because he's dying
obviously because he has tuberculosis
and he looks like hell you know what I
mean
um but
I I guess like in real life I was
reading this thing about
um and somebody was commenting on you
know how maybe how accurate the
portrayal that Val Kilmer had done and
somebody that said well I've read a lot
of books about
um about Doc Holliday like you know from
people that knew him and [ __ ] like that
like you know uh Records a few people
that knew him and they said probably
that's about 50 accurate they said that
he because he was dying
um he got into sort of like a very
nihilistic like headspace because he's
like hey I could die at any minute so
I'm just gonna like [ __ ] drink and
Gamble and [ __ ] like that and not worry
about anything so they're like he was
like that they said he was actually very
educated he was like real sarcastic like
that so I mean that he could have really
been like that I just you know what I
mean I kind of hope I kind of hope he
was because that's like the definitive
portrayal it's just like but he was my
favorite part of the movie I kind of and
he I kind of feel like he's everybody's
favorite part of this movie the movies
honestly if even if it wasn't good it
would be worth watching just for that
but there's like so much other like cool
[ __ ] like on top there's so many cool
scenes there's so many cool lines like
so many quotable lines like one of the
funniest things too is like when you
know Doc Holliday comes out the Saloon
or whatever he's completely plastered
and there's like a [ __ ] uh you know
gunfighter whatever going on out in the
street and they're talking about how
drunk he is and he won't be able to do
it and he's like I got two guns one for
each year yeah it's like one guy could
he see a devil
one for easy
oh my God I laughed out loud like so
every single line of his dialogue is
[ __ ] golden like that whole that
whole scene like in the thing with him
and uh Michael Bain or whatever where
they're having that whole like Latin off
you know and he's like you know Michael
Bates like skill spinning the gun around
and everything and then he just like
starts spinning around the little his
little [ __ ] cup like the booze in it
and he's like looking at him it's like
so [ __ ] funny he's just so so good at
this like every single line that he says
is [ __ ] hilarious and then it's like
sad like and that it's had like that he
dies at the end generally well it's not
really a spoiler alert because that's
what happened in real life but I really
liked that they focused a lot on the
friendship like between Wyatt Earp and
um and Doc Holliday and like that was
kind of like the heart of the movie like
I said I kind of feel like the only
really the only criticism is that I
think they should have taken the romance
of plot out I don't think it needed it
um I think they could have like filler
yeah and I just and I don't know if they
were doing that it's like oh well maybe
it'll appeal to women like if we put the
love story and I'm like you wouldn't
well I'm a woman and I didn't really
need to see that um it's just it was
just thinking that way you know the
dudes were were fine I was like I just
kind of liked the friendship between the
dudes and like all the badass gunfights
and all that kind of stuff so I just
thought that was cool it didn't I didn't
really need any of that stuff but
I don't know this is just conflict it's
such a fun fun entertaining movie and I
was like really glad that Louie sent it
because I probably I mean I'd seen this
before and I liked it but like I said
I'm not a huge generally not like a huge
fan of westerns like I like a lot of
westerns but I don't it's not usually my
go-to genre so I think like if he hadn't
sent it
you know I don't know if we would have
gotten around to reviewing it like maybe
but it would probably be like years we
never would have watched it probably not
no because it's just not one that I
would have thought of necessarily but
then like seeing it again I'm just like
oh yeah I forgot I had never seen it but
then seeing it I was like okay I know
why Louie's sending it to me yeah yeah
it's great flick well plus it's Crustle
and you love it yeah yeah but just never
think about it Kurt Russell did a good
job there was a couple scenes where he's
trying to be tough as [ __ ] and I'm not
really buying it all right I'm like
[ __ ] crust so put some bass in your
voice all right [ __ ] but that's just
the way crussle was sometimes you know
what I mean he wasn't a big guy and he
wasn't on a bunch of tests and uh he
didn't really have that [ __ ] deep
voice
but that was just
it fit the movie that's the way it
[ __ ]
Wyatt Earp probably was I mean I did
love that slow boat no I did love that
like that made me laugh earlier but yeah
it is kind of like that and I was I have
to say like Powers Booth is great in
this deal like he plays Curly Bill and
he also like choose the scenery and it's
amazing and awesome he's just like he
might as well be like twirling his
mustache man like he's such like a bad
guy but it's so so fun now a forgotten
Western that I [ __ ] liked it was just
badass was Red's son
okay I remember really liking that movie
yeah red Sun was really good I think I
might have seen that in the theater and
it's forgotten yeah 70s it had the guy
who was who was the lead
from Torah Tora Tora the Japanese actor
it's about Japanese samurais that fall
in to a wild west situation and
um
the [ __ ] samurais being
beat up slash lead
by an American Outlaw
played by
um what's the guy from [ __ ] um
from
[ __ ]
from [ __ ] yeah yeah the guy from [ __ ]
the guy from the [ __ ]
now she's [ __ ] me up
um
oh man now Louie said uh Red Sun with
Charlie Charles Bronson Charles Bronson
that's what I was thinking yeah Charles
Brown yeah Louie's here I didn't
remember it's been a long time Charles
Bronson and the [ __ ] woman's got him
Toray Mr fumi or whatever he's a famous
Japanese actor who is in Torah Tora Tora
and that was a dark ass [ __ ] movie
okay and it was kind of drawn parallels
between
old west Fighters
both North American and South American
because the Mexicans were in it too so
were so are the Indians and the samurai
how they were all kind of very similar
yeah they have great movie but this is a
good movie too uh it's just that [ __ ]
Red Sun was from an earlier age
more simple
this would this movie was a high budget
[ __ ] all-star cast movie and then
when it came out everybody was talking
about it what team is down Tombstone
yeah Tombstone everybody's talking about
has anybody seen the Kevin Costner Wyatt
Earp movie that came out like after this
one uh I never saw it but I heard it was
pretty good
because I feel like nobody really
remembers this one but like that one but
everybody remembers this one because
this one did a lot better like this one
like made a lot more money
um than Wyatt Earp did and I don't know
if that's just because it's like hey we
already saw a wider movie this year so
what the [ __ ] or if that was like um a
testament to like maybe the Kevin
Costner one wasn't that great but like I
I don't even remember if I saw the Wyatt
Earp one but yeah it's just funny that
that's but that happens a lot I feel
like because it's like see you know
sometimes like ideas kind of get around
and it's like everybody's working on
their own [ __ ] and you know yeah but
Louie you're right it's a good flick
it's good flick we enjoyed it uh what's
the next one we gotta watch
uh
Hey Santa's platoon and so we'll talk
about that and then we're gonna we gotta
do
um uh [ __ ] Godfather two and three
two yeah we still gotta do those yeah
we're gonna do guys I know I feel really
bad that we haven't got around yeah at
least we did the first we got him up on
top we don't suck that much I remember
like liking Godfather
I think a lot of people do yeah that's
kind of one of those you know how people
are just like oh the very rare thing
with like a sequel is better than the
original a lot of people bring up
Godfather too yeah I was like Gotham too
oh yeah and she was the [ __ ] and I
remember three being good that they were
all good but I remember two being better
than one yeah I remember that too I
don't remember anything about three
though right it's been like [ __ ] been
a long time I remember that one was also
satisfying
yeah kind of Watson is saying uh yeah I
saw the wide art movie uh it's better in
my opinion why it is a better movie okay
interesting yeah I don't know it might
be like I from what I understand like I
said I haven't seen Wyatt Earp from what
I could gather from like reviews that I
read was that some people thought Wyatt
Earp was like maybe objectively
technically like a better movie but that
this one was a more entertaining and
memorable movie
say Khan check out [ __ ] Red Sun all
right Charles Bronson
you'll like it you'll like it fourth
throw down said have you reviewed bone
Tomahawk yes we have yeah that is an
awesome great awesome seriously I love
that movie I love that movie and that's
almost like a western except at the end
when it very much turns into a horror
movie
with one of the grossest one of the
grossest scenes that you're uh probably
ever likely to say
Danny rolling said has anyone seen the
2015 werewolf movie called Hal where a
stop train gets attacked by werewolves
yes honestly we might have done a
matinee on that because I remember
watching it it's British right I
remember that being pretty good I
remember that being pretty good yeah
it's like a
yeah like werewolves come out like
attack people on a train yeah it's it's
good I don't remember where we saw it
but I'm pretty sure that we did a
matinee on it all right so tomorrow
we're gonna do it's Monday so we're
gonna do a haunting yeah now does
anybody have any suggestions for
haunting episodes I mean we have a
million of them so it's like if nobody
has any suggestions we'll just come up
with something what one second uh Khan
no it's not Sean Connery all right red
sun has
um Charles Bronson Charles Bronson and a
Japanese famous Japanese actress
and it's a it's a samurai
cowboy movie having to do with Mexico
you'll [ __ ] you'll like it you'll
like it it's really good
but uh yeah so I don't know I'm gonna
wait for a couple minutes and see if
anybody has any haunting episodes
suggestions because we always like to do
ones that
um you know that people like and that
you want to be suggested but you know
what I mean we have a million like if
you don't uh Danny rolling said the
apartment episode with the white and
Asian couple where they're haunted by a
murder victim of a drug dealer episode
um which one was that I think I kind of
remember which one have we done that one
I feel like if we haven't done that we
might have watched it recently because
that sounds really familiar
hmm I don't remember that I'll have to
check like the Wikipedia you got to give
us the title yeah like what yeah because
their titles are just because the titles
are all about the same so we have to
know exactly what Tyler you're talking
about we get confused over which one is
which we'll see remember how that whole
that whole thing happened with like
Echoes from the grave and or Echoes of
the grave and Echoes from the past or
something like that I thought that was
the same episode but uh you know they're
they're not yeah uh it's in either
season one wait season one through four
or either season one or season four
Danny Rowling said hold on he'll find it
okay that's that's fine yeah I kind of
remember what one you're talking about
but yeah yeah Khan you'll like red Sun
it's a samurai slash cowboy movie
western movie and they're trying to get
to Mexico
it's a good flick Charles Bronson
Charles Brown Charles Bronson yeah
Charles Brown and it was a hit in the
United States and in Japan
in the 70s when it came out it was real
good
um kind of outside what series is that
haunting yeah it well it was on it's not
still on is it now
um it used to be yeah but it's going to
be it started out on Discovery I feel
like way back in like the early 2000s
mid-2000s something yeah and then like
it moved to Destination America it went
on for like 12 or 13 Seasons I think we
did Haunting in Summerwind that was when
we did once we did yeah because that's
like Tom's favorite yeah that's my
favorite episode yeah so yeah we did
actually I think we've done a couple
episodes because didn't we do an episode
where we had that guy that was on the
Summer Wind
is a guy who owns Summer Wind trying and
he was on the show
yeah well he would no I don't think he
owned it he was just trying to um he
lived there though for a while right no
I don't I thought he did okay no the
project yeah he was just like on the um
Summer Wind restoration project okay
okay and they were trying to like get it
like we're trying to get rebuilt or
whatever because yeah like it's not
there anymore pretty much just the chips
we have two episodes also yeah I think
we did two of them but I mean the one
that we it was like old I don't even
think it was I don't even think we were
uh doing video at that point I think it
was just like audio
but I mean we could I thought he had
lived on the premises I don't think so I
don't think so what's his name his name
is Joshua something yeah that's right a
long time ago yeah he's on my uh not
Instagram but um yeah LinkedIn he's on
my LinkedIn
uh Louis says Tom and Jenny if you guys
have Paramount plus I recommend the
offer uh the making of The Godfather
it's really good oh okay that does sound
good I like making of like documentaries
uh kind of awesome said I remember but
I've never seen those episodes I thought
there were some Unsolved Mysteries
episodes no the apartment is the episode
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah they're just
[ __ ] paranormal the first three or
four seasons were really good
and they started to go downhill but they
were they were the each one of those
episodes was better than a horror movie
yeah I mean they weren't better than all
horror movies they were better average
better than an average or yeah they were
like they were like better than [ __ ]
um yeah season four episode four yeah
okay that helps yeah that was actually
one of the ones we were thinking about
doing we might have watched it recently
look at how cute Jenny's glasses are
he bought he bought these for me they're
[ __ ] cute and I got her some other
ones that were like costume big round
clubs right with these ones are reading
glasses because like I said I was like I
actually need these to see because
otherwise everything on the screen is
just a big blur yeah the first ones I
bought were just big round ones they're
[ __ ] huge oversized [ __ ] round
ones he's get he he's having a 70s retro
yeah those are cute those would be cute
for the for the uh for the little
[ __ ] uh uh photos that you do for
this for the for the show the little
icon type photos
she's like yeah but I need him to read
so so I got her that was also yeah
because I was like I'm not just wearing
those like for a fashion statement like
for a picture I'm wearing them because I
can't see but I got her some for a
fashion statement she could wear those
out to the club where are those things
where are they they're right there
they're right there I just thought that
was really funny like that he thought
that I was just wearing those little
glasses like for for fashion I was like
look at how cute these are I was like no
because I was like okay but I'm not
gonna be able to see anything I'm just
like no I'm Gonna Make Her wear that
with her [ __ ] blue wigs and [ __ ] when
she goes out to the [ __ ] club look
how cute those are well everybody every
big kid could be saying like Okay but I
don't know because it's blurry because
these ones are just have glasses I think
they're very cute
no I can kind of see does it look so
good look at they're [ __ ] big they're
big I gotta that would look like I said
he's having a 70s retro yeah so cute
like her [ __ ] wigs on her [ __ ]
her outfits are the big titties and [ __ ]
and these are just like round round
round round round and it's just yeah
come on
this is also having like a round yeah
yeah can I put the other ones on now put
them on now baby so I can see put them
on now okay I can't see what those are I
think they're cute I'm just saying that
you're a hilarious person well I'm gonna
do what I want to do I'm gonna do it
Adriana said ravenous is another good
Western too oh my God I recommend
ravenous to everybody like if you like
westerns it's not exactly a western it's
a horror movie but it's in like a
western setting and it's like a
cannibalish wendigo movie and it's
really really good Khan says Tom likes
big things yeah why I'm not surprised
yeah
hell yeah ah
Zach says I think big 70s glasses look
good on people mine basically look like
that yeah I mean you know
I was skeptical like when I first saw
them because I was like I never really
liked the big 70s glasses but I guess
they look good on my face I don't know
yeah what that's the new style man you
guys I know it is I got this new goth
girl everything's like right they're all
guffed out like they're [ __ ] wearing
these big old [ __ ] glasses it's cute
cute yeah let's I'll allow it I don't
really like the return of mom jeans
though
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] mom geez
I I like more 70s [ __ ] hip-hugger
[ __ ]
um uh bell bottom jeans they look so
much better yeah hip hugger bell bottoms
sexy I'm not in it mom jeans were never
sexy never yeah I'm not really into the
high-waisted things because honestly
like high-waisted jeans look good on
maybe one or two percent of the
population yeah no like most people
can't wear those because it just doesn't
look right no she would look awesome in
[ __ ] low Hip Huggers with [ __ ]
bell bottoms well I have like platforms
like that and those big old glasses with
her [ __ ] blue wigs and her boobs
they're [ __ ] yeah Zach said I also
like the no makeup makeup look from the
70s too I don't know why yeah I get what
you're saying yeah I get what you're
saying I was thinking about that when I
was watching the Thai West movie X yeah
even I mean she kind of did that like
Mia goth she kind of had that
um no makeup makeup look although she
did have the like Frosty blue eyeshadow
which was like a thing yeah which I
don't love I don't love the frosty blue
eyeshadow but it looked good on her
though and like lip gloss and she had
like all the freckles you know what I
mean
so she looked good girls that look like
that though first of all they had to be
young they have really well yeah she's
like and then they they have to have
[ __ ] pubic hair there's just
something about it well it's a whole
thing it's a whole aesthetic yeah if
you're gonna go the whole hog
you know yeah meanwhile meanwhile people
that tuned in like thinking we were
going to be talking about why are you
talking about 70s pubic hair yeah that's
how it happened we don't know either we
don't know either it just happens I grew
up in California in the 70s 70s and 80s
I remember it
yeah
we can tie it back in with Tombstone
without talking about everybody's
mustaches yeah right yeah which is like
facial pubic hair yeah
I'm just teasing you to I love you Tom
you know that [ __ ] man I tease because I
love past couple [ __ ]
oh here we go days me and you man
[ __ ] been killing it
I ain't gonna talk about that right now
you just did I just did Taco
okay you were drunk as [ __ ] yeah he came
with the first thing he said when he got
back from the bar because like I said
he's been gone for five hours I don't
think he's been at the well I don't
think he's been at the bar for five
hours have you because you were riding
almost yeah I ran I rode for about an
hour that's what I was gonna say you
were riding around here yeah yeah I
wrote it for about an hour but the first
thing he said when he came home yeah I
came back I could tell that he was like
drunk when he came in yeah like because
he was they were taking kind of banging
around yeah and he said and the first
thing he said was like oh Amy took care
of me like only charged me like less
only charged cars 20 and I was like well
wait how how much was the Tab supposed
to be about 40. oh my goodness yeah she
was giving me doubles but she but then
after she's like I'm gonna charge you
for singles I said okay I'll give you
10. uh so yeah I worked I worked that's
what I mean man it's like well I mean I
okay just give me doubles though
I just I'm having a drink right now and
I and I had one drink last night
I posted that [ __ ] somebody writing I
mean Friday night though we drank so
much because like we drank on the show
and then we went to mannequins afterward
yeah I didn't feel like all that drunk
though I guess because he danced a lot
you know what I mean so it's like it
wasn't like I was just like standing
there yeah and blah blah blah and plus I
like ate a sandwich and stuff when I got
home so I felt all right I was kind of
just kind of tired the next day that's
all
um oh and another thing I wanted to say
too is that uh I don't think DJ Maniac
is here but um he's the one that sent me
the book that I'm going to be reviewing
which is uh an anthology of quote
unquote found footage like short stories
and normally if you are on our patreon
page I would have already posted the
video because you'd get like Early
Access so I would usually have put it up
like this morning but I haven't finished
the video yet I did finish reading the
book which was awesome by the way if
you're out there DJ Maniac it was like
really really good
um but I haven't like recorded the but
it's still going to go up tomorrow
though I just it might be later than
usual that's all because I got behind
you kind of still tell me he'll take
care of me if I come to TJ no [ __ ] I
swear to God Khan when I go on vacation
I'll come see you all right we'll come
see you yeah he was talking about that
the other day I said yeah why don't you
yes I was like but if you get like in
trouble don't call me
don't be calling me and it's like you
got no jail somewhere or [ __ ] around
that dude or you got some kind of like
disease but no or something I was just
like don't call me
now I'm gonna come see you and your sons
I'm [ __ ] proud of this since I'm your
you know you tell your sons that that uh
I'm their uncle and [ __ ] up we'll
come down we'll go I want to see your
swimming pool we've got a nice swimming
pool in the back and we'll drink and uh
yeah man you show me around Tijuana well
we'll have a good time we'll have a good
time go to a donkey show yeah
[Laughter]
it's just [ __ ] don't be calling me
from a dog I went to a donkey show I'm
not gonna be there long I'm gonna go
down here and see what [ __ ] const up to
and we'll get some food and get some
Mexican food and kind of answers that I
promised only VIP brothels Jenny I mean
like yeah make sure that shit's clean if
you want that locked down oh man we
can't I don't want you breaking like
some weird diseases home yeah come back
with all kinds of Cooties
that sounds like some [ __ ] you would do
no I'm gonna come I'm gonna come see you
Khan I'm gonna come see you I'm gonna
come see you [ __ ] it because that's my
home anyway you know Southern California
yeah I was actually born in [ __ ] Long
Beach
even though I'm [ __ ] a child in the
South down in Mississippi and everything
but yeah yeah but I [ __ ] growing up
in Brazil nah man I need to go back to
South America for a while
get back to where I grew up from
let's go back to your roots go back to
my roots your roots my roots yeah we'll
have fun man Ian England said uh I used
to go to a bar called the glory hole
what that's a game that's a gay bar I
mean it might be
um
and the [ __ ] bartender was a
buddy of mine I drink all day and Tab
out and he'd say you only had one beer
right yeah I kind of feel like that's
what you have at the Oasis that's back
when you were hanging out down at the
manhole
and the ramrod I'm trying to remember
there was a gay bar in Daytona Beach
where I grew up what the [ __ ] was the
name of that thing I just always
remember because I always remember
because the name made me laugh because
you know I'm a child but it's like oh
well I funnier than the name which I
can't actually remember right now but
funnier than the name was like the sign
which actually kind of looked like a
rocket like it looked like a like a
rocket like with like you know [ __ ]
coming out about like fire coming out
the back and that used to always make me
laugh I don't know why I mean it was
like a really cheesy looking sign too
but it's like I don't know I thought it
was funny it's pretty easy to amuse me I
wish I could remember the name of that
place it wasn't that clever like it
wasn't quite as clever as like you know
the manhole or something but I don't
know it used to make me laugh I don't
remember what it is now though I don't
remember what it is all right so are you
um
are you done because you see you seem
like you're pretty like uh [ __ ] up I'm
molesting I know so we're gonna do the
apartment right yeah but yeah we'll do
the apartment okay okay okay all right
so um we'll be back tomorrow talking
about knocking off now I'm gonna do what
I want to do knock it off I'm gonna do
what I want to do
[Laughter]
dger stuff I'm gonna do it what you're
so drunk no it's just reason it's it's
really not but it's freezing it's okay
no it totally makes sense Lily said
Tom's super faded
he really is he really is stop it okay
stop stop it okay I'm gonna leave it
alone don't be so weird this is how it
is I'm trying to make she making me
leave it alone you're on a live stream
for Christ's sake did you forget where
you were I know where I am no you don't
all right I'm just trying to get
somebody a [ __ ] don't be gross yeah you
are yeah you are no
all right so we'll be back tomorrow talk
about a haunting like I said we're gonna
do the apartment so thank you for the
recommendation like I said that was on
my list anyway so we would have got
around to that eventually
you know what I mean uh Zach says I mean
we could always move the show to
ChatterBait yeah
that [ __ ] my hash oh my God
yeah like you said this started with
Tombstone and ended up being x-rated I
don't know how that happened well I know
how it happens because Tom's [ __ ] up
that's why Zach you would love it and
I'm gonna get the camera angle and
everything all right whatever don't look
at gross all right so we'll be back
tomorrow yeah same time same bath
Channel we'll be talking about haunting
so hopefully you guys can come and join
us so uh have a good rest of your
weekend you guys good night